Saoirse Ronan is Mary Queen of Scots
opposite Margot Robbie's Queen Elizabeth
the first in the upcoming historical
drama that is basically a real-life Game
of Thrones
it's crazy when I was doing my research
I was like oh yeah because this was back
when people lived to be 40 and these
were teenage girls like running yeah
yeah yeah should you learn to me
remember you murder your sister and you
murder your Queen when Mary Queen of
Scots tries to overthrow her cousin
Queen Elizabeth the first and claimed
the throne to England for herself it's
an epic power struggle but what's almost
crazier than this true story is the time
it took to get the looks just right now
here's no clothes for Margot recreating
Elizabeth's pockmarked features meant
spending three to four hours a day in
makeup what is it like the first time
you see yourself in this transformation
it was wonderful all the prosthetics
particularly it is glue and plastic
essentially so it restricted my my face
and my facial expressions a lot and I
felt kind of trapped by you know this
image Elizabeth created for herself it
was poetically resonant even Joe Alwyn
Taylor Swift Current Flame dyed his hair
for his role as Robert Dudley it's his
second period piece this year he also
stars opposite Emma Stone and Rachel
vice in the favorite what was harder
doing the breakdancing scene with Rachel
or getting beat up by Emma Stone they
were both a lot of fun you know I love
like doing the in particularly not the
big observed physical moments and they
learned a lot of fun to do and we know
Taylor enjoyed both because girlfriend
loves to dance she gave a solid review
of her man's film to her 113 million
Instagram followers with the caption
absolutely phenomenal and get this so
romantic she tagged Joe in the post
[Music]
[Applause]